we read freak week out loud at VidCon it
was an amazing time with amazing people
and I see some clips from that yeah of
course you do I know check it out you
know video riding with grace it's Friday
with grace cuz I really don't want to
write this whole thing by myself it's
writing with grace writing with me me my
name is Grace I would like to introduce
you to some of the amazing people that
will be bringing your words to life
Alima
mamrie Hart ear robot diary
my name is lace petty small just try and
gender by phenomena like she doesn't get
bored and start the batter eyes and one
legged Johnny over in the saloon or a
smile at three-toed Trevor at the end
we're hoping for the college roommate
Nancy in the bathroom of the DMV when
you're trying to take your eye test for
any Catholic dogs out there it was
literally raining cats and dogs the
classic should just work out Greek Week
has begun casually discussing can opener
shirt shirt ship soup and I became one
Thank You Dorchester
becomes buried forever you think you can
beat me your brain is movie truth we did
it and we did it and we said it and we
did it and there's a million ways that
you can check out freak week you read it
on Wattpad Wattpad calm such writing
with you can go to the ATT Helen lab
YouTube page and watch the entire freak
week live read looking the link in the
description you can imagine what it's
like in your head there's a variety of
ways to do it there's only one way for
me to thank you
I'll see you on the Internet I don't
know